you
great hi so I'm David Kennedy class of
98 here at Stanford and as Peter said I
did a search fund for a while a company
called service source which my partner
Mike who I bought it with is still
running and thankfully it's it's still
growing I ultimately left there and
founded a private equity firm called
serán Capital that and we invest in
growth businesses we take control
transaction or we do we take control
positions and transactions that don't
look too dissimilar from the classic
search fund and so it's kind of
interesting having been on one side of
the table I'm kind of on the other one
now a little bit and that and I think
that informs my perspective a wee bit
I guess my comments would be just first
of all I thought Florian did a terrific
job at the very start and it's never
easy to be the first cold call at the
very first class and I thought he did a
neat job of laying out a whole bunch of
the significant issues that you have
when you think about entrepreneurship
through acquisition and then these
different models not least of which was
the whole question about a the
opportunity cost which I think he called
out sort of very quickly I think one of
the things that's easy to forget is what
the opportunity cost is and of course
it's always hard for us if you don't
know what our careers otherwise might
have looked like I also feel like
sometimes with these panels used to call
it out quickly you're typically going to
get the guys where everything's gone
fairly well um nobody tends to come to
these panels and say hey I'm the I'm the
bottom quartile and I'd like to tell you
about what it's like down there at the
bottom and I think that there are
significant opportunity costs associated
with doing the search fund to me the
fact that the me search fund return is
negative and where you lose half of your
capital tells you something the fact
that you know you really have to get
into the top decile to make terrific
returns in the top quartile to make
decent ones I can tell you having been
fortunate enough to be somebody who's at
that end of the bell curve that an awful
lot of that ends up being rough being
luck rather than anything else it's kind
of random events that happen it's
companies that you're fortunate enough
to stumble across we're doing your
searching it's the fact that your key
customers don't disappear in your first
couple of years as I think back to the
guys who done search funds when I was
first doing my search fund we've been
fortunate enough to have done better
than most and I think that if you had
rank ordered me and my partner against
all the other guys were doing to search
fun at the same time we probably in
somewhere around the middle of the pack
in terms of capability and I think that
tells you something I think is you think
about doing a search fund particularly
most the folks in this room
you've always been top decile and
everything you've done most you've been
top percentile at everything you've ever
done everyone always assumes are going
to be in that top decile
case the reality is that everybody who
does a search for under the vast
majority of them are people like that
yeah and there's an awful lot of luck
that ends up going into what happens for
me at least that's my belief on the
search front side that's one comment one
further comment there was a great
conversation I think here around control
and and I think that one of the things
that Peter and David asked us to do is
to think about what we've learned over
time and I think that to me has been one
of the biggest learnings that I had I
think for me knee jerk doing a search
fond I wanted a very distributed search
fund I deliberately set up my search
fund such that nobody had more than one
unit and we'd 15 units so that I could
control my own destiny and I thought
that was generally kind of a good thing
in retrospect what I was kind of saying
was I'd like to have make sure that none
of my investors actually cares all that
much of what's going on inside of my
business and that no one can stop me if
I'm gonna make some mistakes and now on
the other side of that sitting on the
private equity world and also having sat
on a couple of search fun boards where
things didn't go terribly well and I
think there's an awful lot of value in
having a concentrated set of owners who
will help you and will put the time in
to make sure that you don't make
mistakes and also to help you in terms
of what it is that you're doing with
your search and so if you think about
the classic private equity flow chart if
you will they're sourcing their steel
execution and then there's working with
the business post clothes having us
having a concentrated ownership in
whatever way it's going to be means
you're more likely to have folks who
will be able to help you in all of those
elements and whether it's on the
sourcing side of things where it's on
the execution side of things and
diligence and and in particular they
will challenge you pretty hard on the
assumptions that you have around the key
decisions you're going to make inside of
the business both in the acquisition
itself and then subsequently as I look
at some of the search ones that haven't
gone so well and I think many of them
would have benefited a great deal from a
concentrated owner who would have sat
there and said hang on a sec have you
really done the diligence on this and
maybe done some of their own diligence
to check some of the numbers would have
spent time with the CEO of the
management team in between the board
meetings as opposed to simply just one
Supporter and I think that might have
been a better that might have been a
better outcome and knowing some of the
ones that didn't go all that well and so
you know for me I think that's sort of
that leads you to a bit of an answer
from my perspective as you think about
how to do this if you're if you're going
to do it in the first place and which is
one of the things that's in the case and
somebody I think mentioned it already is
you know the rank order outcomes here as
you buy a terrific company you don't buy
a company and you're by a company that's
anything other than actually if a
company and that includes the ones that
are mediocre were you going to spend
five to six years your life making not
very much money for investors and not
very much money for you I think you want
to do everything you possibly can to
make sure that you end up in the top of
those which is buying a terrific company
and if not buy a terrific company then
don't buy anything at all and for me
that tends to mean that you're better
off if you can on the sponsored search
because I think that's more likely to
make sure you don't end up there now the
pushback that came out in the class was
a sponsored search isn't something
that's available immediately for most of
us and and certainly wasn't available
for me as I was leaving business school
and also even as I did my search one
which is sort of two three years after
going out of here and I think that's
right and I think that that's life and
and I think that in general I think that
in general management and senior
management is an apprenticeship game and
I think that the concept that says I'm
28 years of age and I've done two or
three years of work experience in I have
an MBA from Stanford and I've spent two
years doing the you know the the looking
at hypothetical cases were in the CEO GE
and does not necessarily suit you all
that well to being a CEO and I think
that it's perfectly okay to go through a
process of actually learning and and of
picking up skills where that's on the
sales or the operational side of things
before you actually leave off and take
the biggest risk of your career which is
other people's money and other people's
company's employees that work for you
customers who are relying on you and all
the risk you have to take there I don't
think it's necessarily a bad thing to
spend you know sort of four to eight
years or call of what you will building
up some operational expertise that
you're ready to do it
interesting topic I'm both there and
Sean sure and so first up David usually
says exactly what's on my mind just more
articulately so I'll keep it pretty
brief to start I spent some time after
business school actually doing a number
of operational roles which culminated in
me being the general manager of a
European division of a software company
that was sold it was at that time I
decided I wanted to pursue running
running a company preferably my own
company and I did not have a rich uncle
so I you know I went through a lot of
what you guys are talking through in
this class ended up thinking the
sponsored search was was right for me
and you know I think a lot of the the
answers are it depends on what you want
to do it depends on the partner that you
pick you know for me I I totally
appreciate the concerns about control
that came up but you know I guess we
were talking about it outside and to me
you know what I learned through that
process and after the fact is doing a
good job will allow you the control that
you want and need because the private
equity firm you know what they're
looking for is good businesses and great
managers and if you're the latter you
know you're in good shape you're gonna
and by the way as David said you're
pushing yourself to be tested in the
acquisition process but else when you
run in the business which i think is
what we all want and me personally I was
not although I had been involved in
selling and buying a couple companies I
was not a deal person so what they
brought to me to bear on the M&A aside
was actually very valuable to me so I
you know it was a very good experience
but I felt a good level of trust with
them so I think that that was what is
important because and I'll give you the
the French since we talked about why I
think experience it you know is least
was important for me every you know some
people I think could could jump in and
and could swim I felt like I wanted to
be prepared and when when I was ready to
search for a company I felt confident
that I would do the investors and the
organizations I'm running
in that role and that was important to
me personally but you know was a great
company that we bought the investment
thesis we really we all liked you know I
made it through a bunch of rounds with
with the private equity firm we bought
it its high-end modern furnishings and
that was approximately five days before
Lehman Brothers imploded and our largest
market was New York City while they were
national and so I didn't find that
scenario anywhere in the investment
thesis so the point is you know then I
was like man I'm glad I can at least
rely on some experience saying okay I
can throw the plan out the window now we
got to go to what's really in front of
us and I'm not sure I would have been
comfortable doing that at 28 or 30 but
you know of course we all advanced at
our own pace so it was like you know I
think the control piece I understand but
but also its own negotiable so I had the
right of first refusal in my agreement
if they didn't want to back the company
that I want to invest in I actually had
the right to just basically they would
it was like they had bought the units in
the search phone so again you know be
flexible don't think it has to fit up
everything's the same David already
talked about the risks I think there are
there's professional risks and in
there's there's financial risk and we'll
talk I think a little bit more about
them finally I just leave it with figure
out where your passions at you know we
talked about I'd worked for a couple of
venture-backed startups in my career and
I just that wasn't me I wasn't that guy
that had the killer idea whether you
know whether it was technology which was
I was in or just something different
that wasn't me what really fires me up
is taking an organization agreeing on a
vision developing a culture which by the
way even though it's an ecstatic company
trust me you can put your your footprint
your stamp on that for sure and
achieving great things together that's
what fires me up I've got to engineering
the reason I run an Internet Retailer so
you know it wasn't what again I'd
figured out but I loved it so that's it
sure sir so I'm the the self Thunder
which is someone correctly pointed out
doesn't necessarily mean you don't take
other people's money and you have to
have it all yourself but you you are the
one that's funding the search and I
chose that path because I had a very
geographic specific area I wanted to
live in for reasons just family I wanted
to stay in Northern California and my
search area was basically San Jose to
the North Bay East Bay and the peninsula
so I wanted to be in that area and I
wanted to leverage off some very
specific industry experience I had in
the past I felt like I had some
investors that I could go out and I
could find the right company so I didn't
feel like I needed to go take other
people's money in the form of a search
fund and I didn't really think they
would allow me to have those kinds of
restrictions which were pretty
significant the majority control thing
covered the control thing comes up again
because I also felt like I wanted to
have control now as it turns out that
that's a that's a false need you've
already said it competences control and
so actually after eight years you know I
can
I'm coming full circle because I'm
actually selling my company should be
closed at the end of this month and the
due diligence is done and everything so
knock on wood but and and I'm gonna be
the CEO of the company that's acquiring
me in return for a small percentage of
the company and but now I've actually
got a platform I've got a company that's
large you know it's gonna mean eight
million dollar company for the employees
I actually have competent middle
management I'm gonna be able to do much
bigger things with that minority
ownership and there's no way they're
gonna get rid of me
I mean I've looked at their books I need
me and so you know it this whole notion
of control it really is more about kind
of what do you bring to the table and
and it took me a while to get there but
I'm finally there and and and looking
really optimistic about the future and
what what that holds for me yeah we're
gonna we're gonna both speak
simultaneously
pick one and listen my name is Lucas
Braun I was the class of 2007 at the GSB
upon graduation Ryan and I launched
Braun robbing capital as a search fund
we searched for 14 or so months and then
found a business and acquired that over
the next six months or so it's a
commercial data center services business
called on-ramp it's located in Austin
Texas which in the search phone world
short of buying a business on Union
Street in San Francisco Roseburg Lombard
cotton sorry that's much worse is it's a
pretty big win I just want I want to
make a couple of comments that I heard
during the initial conversation which I
thought was productive and I thought you
know how did many of the issues that
Ryan and I were considering when we were
evaluating our our next professional
step I heard a lot of folks talk who's
in pinyin whose opinions appear to be
informed by the notion that that your
knowledge going into this is is
stationary or at a point in time and I'd
like to add that most of what I've done
on this journey has been an evolution I
think you start the search knowing two
or three industries you might be
interested in you look at 2,000
businesses over the course of two years
you have a much better sense for what
you like and don't like along the way so
some of these these issues that were
discussed around what should I be
looking for in an investor set well it's
really hard to know if you were to read
our original ppm I think you'd be fairly
embarrassed with the industries we were
interested in candidly so I mean I would
just encourage you to acknowledge that
you will be growing along the way and
and part of what was attractive to me in
this process was I'd be growing along
with a group of investors that had
already done a number of comparable
experiences whether that was M&A I think
David covered it perfectly well in terms
of the skill sets you should be looking
for in your investor group if you have
the if you have the luxury of being
picky about investors and the second
part of that was the ability to do it
with a partner I think I did I did a
fair amount of introspection during this
process and was
relatively clear in my own head that
this wasn't something I felt comfortable
doing alone and I was fortunate enough
to have the ability to do it with
someone who complimented me from the
skill set and experience perspective but
also from an emotional disposition
perspective I mean the the the amplitude
of the waves of the ups and downs in
this process are so much more pronounced
than you know before you go in so it's
great to have someone to say you know
we'll get them next time or are you
crazy that's the worst to story ever why
you spending time on that or you know to
laugh about a cold call that goes
terribly awry because they will and so
that was a big part of my decision
process and then the one other point I'd
make about some of the discussion I
heard was really thinking through what
your opportunity costs are I think and
defining what failure means to you for
for me I didn't view this as something
that would the downside wasn't that
great for me personally I was you know I
had a girlfriend then fiancee I wasn't
geographically attached to any one place
I felt that if I treated all of my
investors ethically and responsibly and
relatively and made relatively
intelligent decisions along the way you
know you know you you'd have another
crack of the whip I think we all
graduate from the GSB with an
unhealthful e wonderful sense of
professional invincibility so I would
encourage you to rethink what your your
failure means I don't necessarily think
it's I pull heartedly agree with David
that the worst case scenario is actually
buying an underperforming business but
you know maybe you grow a business at a
15% clip for five years you make
wonderful professional accomplishments
you get a win under your belt which is
something or for us back loves to talk
about and then you figure out what you
want to do next so for me I viewed it as
more of an if not now when
kind of a prospect so I'm Ryan Robinson
also a class of 2007 I wanted to start
off by thanking Gus and you're my boy
Lou for sticking up for the traditional
search fund you guys did a great job
kind of walking through the
the pros especially in the cons of the
traditional search and I think one thing
that came out is that you know there are
a lot of pros and cons for all these
different models and they exist kind of
at different points on a risk/reward
curve and one thing that Peter brought
up at the end is a lot of this is very
personal so you know where you feel
comfortable on that risk reward curve
and you know risk Ward isn't all dollars
and cents there's also you know
professional risk credibility risk and
there are lots of different things that
play into that that kind of makeup where
you think these different these
different avenues of entrepreneurship
kind of fall on that curve and so it's
important to kind of keep those in
perspective as you're thinking through
what your options are what one of my
favorite things I heard was from Chris
who said it's not as glorious as we're
making it out to be sometimes you're
talking about you know moldy food in the
refrigerator we haven't had to deal with
that yet but it's not glorious so there
are definitely times where we're dealing
with things where we look at each other
and say I can't believe that I just
spent an hour of my life talking about
you know the food in the refrigerator
that being said that's not how we spend
most of our day talking about what's in
the refrigerator so you get much more of
a spectrum of you know what what
products should we be launching how
should we be handling our largest
customer who just had a customer service
issue and it's talking about leaving and
then you also have somebody took my
parking space you deal with much more of
you know a wider range and everything in
between but Lucas brought it up I think
opportunity cost is also I feel like I'm
making a lot of touchy feely comments
even though the the numbers guy and in
our relationship but I think opportunity
cost is another area where there was a
lot of discussion about opportunity
costs and I don't that I also don't
think that that's all about dollars and
cents so you know thinking about would
it what really are you giving up when I
look at what I'm doing right now I could
have been making more money in another
profession but I couldn't have been
happier and so when I think about my
opportunity cost it was it was much
lower than you know what you put down on
paper
what I could have modeled an Excel
spreadsheet and then the last thing is
timing you know I think Luca said if not
now when and that that's really kind of
the attitude we had going in that you
know one can say you'll always have the
opportunity but when you think about
yourself in three years five years and
ten years and put yourself in you know
the future use shoes and you've got a
wife a mortgage it's great job that's
paying a whole lot more money than
you're making straight out of business
school you know the opportunity costs
and the decision set changes a lot and
there are a lot more people who are
involved in that decision then right
well when we were doing it it was just
us and our girlfriends who still had a
parachute out if they wanted it let me
start with Michael just in terms of
operating a company you had operating
experience before well first it's very
different than running a P&L I mean that
the P&L is very good experience and
having manage sort of sales and
operations great but it's different when
you can always talk to the CEO at the
end of the day when there's a big
decision has to come down and obviously
now I have the opportunity to the
opportunity to work with the board on
those decisions but it's different and I
and for me different in a good way
because when you're talking about things
like culture strategy vision you really
do get the chance to put your imprint on
it so I again I think that was great
building blocks but but it's varied I
think a very different experience
you Lucas how's it been different
operating business now for one year last
week so I think the biggest difference
from my expectation was that in on paper
you you can you can I can I could
powerpoint the heck out of any problem
right I can think about what the ten
year plan should be and as a result what
the five year plan should be as a result
what the one year plan should be and as
a result what the 15 strategic
initiatives I need to be working on any
given day are and every Monday I go into
the office and I write down the five
things I I desperately want to
accomplish for our business and I'm
lucky if I get to one and a half of them
because there's so many tactical things
that come up along the way so for me I
think my largest challenge thus far has
been you know how how I manage my time
how I how I you know how you how you
make time for this how you make time to
continue to focus on the broader picture
David you bought a company and then
you've started started a company
yourself so you can sort of had both
senses of those could you contrast those
for us how they've been different in
terms of satisfaction and fulfillment
it's a good question
and you know I think there's a lot of
validity to the conversation was going
on you know I actually thought that the
DNA comment and but somebody made up
their course to talk she's she left was
it min I think she's not here anymore
made around and I think when you start
something you responsible for absolutely
everything and both the pros and the
cons you know associated with that and
so it's it's a little bit dear and
deeper I think and I do think on the
other hand that within you know 12
probably 12 months maybe was 24 months
of having bought our company Mike and my
stomp was was pretty heavily on
but there are some things that just
taken off a long time to change I mean
it's really hard to change the culture
in place we were very lucky it was a
terrific culture that we actually and
that we that we got but there were bits
of it that we didn't like and and and
they took an awful long time to get rid
of em at a stamp out and I think it's
very hard to you can't replace your
entire HR organization essentially or
you know County your middle management
and and I think you know 70 to 80
percent of the folks we were thrilled to
have and 20 to 30 we weren't and it took
a while to make some of those changes
and so I think you know the the
something you start yourself with oh
let's just be that touch dearer I think
to your heart than something that you
take over from somebody else and you
just have a little bit more obviously
freedom you 100 percent freedom to make
all the symbolic choices all the hiring
choices all the cultural choices and
when it's your own business and it just
takes a while to shift some but somebody
else's baby switching but how did each
of you guys attract investors and I'll
just go through and and maybe start
Michael with you when you how do you
guys attract investors to your so so for
me I focused on people I knew initially
and because I was buying a very specific
company a very specific industry I went
to people that had I had prior
experience with one of the individuals
actually who ended up investing I worked
with so I was able to go with a lot of
credibility put together business plan
explaining why I thought that this was a
time to buy and and why I thought that I
was the right person to run the company
and there was there was a certain amount
of credibility just out of the gate
because I I wasn't a cold call there
were people that knew of me or work with
me and so primarily it was about selling
myself to people and because I wasn't
buying a very large company and I wanted
to wring majority ownership I didn't
need to raise more than two investors
worth of you know investment from two
investors so I was able to stick to kind
of an inner circle of people who already
had experience with me
we we went after two kinds of people at
the highest level people who either knew
us well or knew the model well and
beyond that it was really hard to kind
of convince someone hey we're good guys
and hey this is a model that can work so
that's where we started at a high level
and we you know went after the people
that either knew us best or knew the
model best first and tried to build some
momentum so we went after you know two
two guys I had worked for that did a
search fund and so they both knew us
well and knew the model intimately so
they were our first investor and I think
the case talks about Irv had said hey
will you call this buddy of mine and so
anything says you do and so we called
this guy and then he said hey I'm in
because he knew the model really well
and then you know you find that it's a
pretty interconnected community and so
as we continue talking different people
we started figuring out you know who who
do we want to work with and who brings
you know all of these things to the
table and I thought I was interesting
that one of the last things to come up
was the deep pockets because you know
you got to start there you want people
well hey they have to have money and
they have to have the money that the
kind of money where this is a small
enough percentage of their net worth
that they can take on this kind of risk
and so you know that that's a pretty
substantial amount of net worth I just
build on that point because it's I think
after having raised a search fund and
then closed an acquisition I think it's
the single biggest good I could impart
onto all of you is that you really do do
you want to have all these other skill
sets but you really do need a couple of
different poles of people if you truly
believe in the value of the search fund
as a way of maximizing your control you
need to have several different poles of
people that could write a big check and
if you look at what's going on in the
world of search fund investing in the
last two to three years you've seen a
pretty large proliferation of the number
of funds so the simple math would tell
you that the average of pro-rata unit
share that an investor might have taken
four years ago they won't take today
because they're getting seven other
deals that look attractive to them and
they'll be participating in some number
of those on a smaller level so really do
you really do want to focus on that the
other thing I'd say just is it's an
interesting different a little bit
different perspective from something we
talked about earlier is Ryan I
explicitly didn't take friends and
family money for some of the reasons we
taught that Peter raised before you know
our initial search fund unit well it
isn't wouldn't have been a consider a
large amount to each of our respective
families but we didn't want to put them
in a position at the time of the deal
whether they're you know writing a check
for an order of magnitude more money and
regardless of whether or not that was a
sum that's palatable to them we didn't
want to redefine the relationship in
that way which i think is something that
is an inevitable side effect of taking
on that kind of an investment it's and
certain folks can do it and I in you
know this is the very personal
realization we had but we didn't want to
come home for a Thanksgiving dinner and
talk about the business we wanted to
talk about being aunts and uncles or
nieces and nephews primarily actually
you know I so that was that that that's
that's a personal decision you have to
make but it was it was one that we
ultimately did what are the numbers you
said people are taking smaller what what
was it what is it now candidly you know
pro rata share for our investment was
$500,000 we had a number of investors
say I'm in for my usual amount which is
two hundred and fifty K which we say
that's great but our equity whole group
I would think realistic to assume half
of what they would usually yeah I think
the search one study says the average
units about thirty thousand dollars now
and ours was thirty five so it was right
in there and then we are telling people
that the check they're gonna write at
acquisition time was gonna be between
two hundred and seven hundred when we
had no idea what company were gonna buy
and how much it was going to cost super
desperate super doesn't we lowered the
bar substantially I did make that
mistake which wasn't the family side of
things mean I deliberately stayed away
from family but my closest friend who'd
been my roommate and everything and who
had done very very well I actually did
take his money and it worked out very
well but it did change the relationship
I mean every time we'd get together and
I'd say hey how's work and he'd tell me
and then he'd say how's work for you and
I'd be like aw crap I'm talking one of
my investors and you know you got to put
a bit of a positive spin on everything
and think a little bit about you know
kind of what you want to say and that
was really awkward and in retrospect
I've never done it even though it worked
out very well for him oh no it was this
is all on me right it wasn't him he
didn't care I mean you know plus we were
doing great you know I mean by we did
very well and so within about a year was
pretty obvious we were going to and and
so he was never worried honestly about
his investment but at some point it sort
of doesn't matter you're playing golf
with somebody and they're your investor
right and they're asking how things are
going and it's just not the same as
playing golf with your best mate and
he's asking you how things are going to
it was just very different same thing
for me is I invested had two investors
where I work with prior but as it turned
out one of the investors had introduced
me to his niece who turned out to be hot
and I married her
so so it ended up sort of backing into
that where you know at family events and
things you you sort of start to think a
little bit about you know what kind of
car you drive and what kind of house you
buy and you know when the numbers aren't
where you want them to be and you're
going out and buying a house and those
things do plays on your mind and even
though he was very good about it because
it was he had enough money that this was
not a meaningful part of his portfolio
it it it impacts you no matter what you
do and certainly you know things are
turning out okay and it but I I just I
there were times when things were really
tough and part of the motivator was
dreading the Christmas conversations
after I'd lost his money and and that
that's that as a powerful motivator so
maybe it works in your favor but not a
conversation I would like to have had
for the rest of my life if things had
gone south so the first was very easy I
picked Mike as my partner
I was just incredibly lucky to have the
guy who I had as my partner just a in in
lots of different ways you know the
funny thing about this and it's it's a
little bit in Lukas and the note on
Lukas and Ryan as well which is kind of
it's very much a Meritage you know and
with all the things that a marriage
means right in as far as there's going
to be good times and that's fantastic
and then there's going to be tough times
and the question is when the chips are
down you know is this the person you
want to have there and at the end of the
day and you know the integrity and the
way that you deal with the tough stuff
is incredibly important and I was just
extraordinarily lucky to have Mike for a
partner and each of us had to deal with
various things that were both personal
and professional where we failed and
during the course of our time working
together and I think that the the
supportive nature of that wasn't why
what about it that is so great
match he matched you or just an
exceptional person or so I think it's
two things and I think it's the overlap
that was there and around what we wanted
to do and values generally and so that
when I always knew that when Mike had a
tough decision to make he would make the
right choice and you know that would be
for him loyalty and a partnership or
just incredibly important and I always
knew that would trump any other
consideration for himself or what have
you and so that was part you know that
was just incredibly important and then I
think on the other side of us we were
just we were a great match I mean we
were very much chalk and cheese and he's
a sales guy and was terrific of bringing
in the revenue which is the only really
important thing it turns out of
businesses everything else is fine so
long as you got you know if you've got
great revenue growth everything else is
sort of nothing and Mike did that and
Mike's created a heck of a lot of value
inside of that company basically yeah
and so that was you know his that skill
set was neat but also there was a I
remember talking to her about this when
we were thinking about going into
partnership together Mike and I and he
talked about the fact that he named us
one of them had been more contemplative
and wanted to get a lot of data to make
a decision I think that was food I think
that was a master of mind and then herb
always wanted to be make the decision
yesterday and let's move on let's go
let's go let's go and we had that and I
think that's an incredibly healthy
tension inside of a partnership so that
was you know that complementarity of of
makeup you know is actually leave aside
all the skills just that you know that's
sort of the different way we thought
about making decisions for to ultimately
is all you're doing as a partnership was
kind of neat so I think that was the
first great thing and let's think the
second I mean almost everything else is
it's less important than that frankly
and you know we probably made one really
terrific hire and so you know that was
pretty important stuff too I mean and I
think particularly you know on the
revenue side of things again I mean
revenue just makes it for everything
else we focus a lot of time Ephram the
tension there first was picking a
partner that I trust no matter how thick
the contract is you never really can
plan for everything that might happen
into having somebody that you trust and
that you can work with when you know
when the situation the ground changed a
little bit so that was wonderful
and that continues to this day and by
the way I went it alone I did not have a
partner and that that felt like the
right thing for me maybe cuz I had a few
more years or just I felt comfortable as
long as I had a good partner helping me
with the M&A aspect of it the other
thing was best thing I did is I walked
away from a deal that I was probably
five months under loi with and I was
right right there in some of the the
terms we're getting changed and you just
also want to just close that deal at
that point but said no thank you walked
away and a you know very happy with the
deal I ended up in but as you guys knows
you you know when you've looked at a
thousand companies gone through a bunch
of letters intent it's very tempting to
just say you know what
alright I'll yield on this get this deal
done then I'll make it up and operating
the company but didn't do that real
quick for me I also didn't have a
partner so going in it's a small company
only two million dollars in revenue when
I bought it and I decided to treat my
two investors even though they're
serving a requirement to as the board
I'd I'd been on executive boards of
venture backed companies or rather
executive teams the venture backed
companies and so I knew what boards
wanted and just to keep myself in the
right mindset I treated them as such
and and that's important because it
isn't glamorous and you get sucked into
so much day-to-day that you you need
some tool or some methodology for
constantly pulling yourself up to think
a little long term things strategically
actually report to someone tell someone
your plans other than yourself so that
helped me stay stay focused and the
second thing was when I when I figured
out kind of what I'd done wrong and I
figured out what my exit strategy was
which was I I needed to merge or be
acquired with someone bigger again it's
taking the time to constantly keep
having the conversations and I kept
talking to other manufacturers letting
them know letting suppliers know hey
we're doing well we're doing great
but I see the future and we need to
merge and I kept talking to people and
the the deal ultimately going to
hopefully come
in 30 days we started having those
conversations four years ago and so it
was that constant like you know staying
focused on the long term and constantly
having this conversation even though any
given day you're working 10 11 12 hour
days and it's it's tempting just to go
home and I'll take that meeting but just
continue to have them so partnership
dynamics were very critical to me I
think everyone's covered on that it
covered them so I'm gonna I'm gonna
discuss two other things
the first I'm going to say is trusting
your instincts on the kind of seller you
buy a business from such a large
percentage of ultimate success and
failure and this is is is reliant
unfortunately upon you know human
intuition and we we looked at a couple
really great businesses with people we
just didn't end up trusting and we ended
up walking away and in retrospect that
was absolutely the right decision Stella
were working the our partner in this
business now because we're doing
something a little bit different we're
ideally our our seller would stay in the
business because a fairly technical
business and and you know he has a
desire to run the technical aspects of
the business but you know he is a
upstanding guy he he was straightforward
in his dealings with us he's a good
heart he's a good person and I think
that's an incredibly important key to
our success thus far the other thing I'd
say is marrying my wife or just being
with my wife in general I think so much
of this process is a journey especially
if you have a partner of some kind is a
journey that you're in control of that
that person has to buy into and the
thing Kate had buy into at the time was
the fact that we could go literally
anywhere in the US or Canada even as the
case may be and we let me tell you we
looked at some places with great
businesses that you know did not rank
high on the quality of life spectrum but
having that support in in in in having
her it'll be on board for that during
the time of our search and then
ultimately in deal time which was you
know as much of like herding cats as
anything we've ever done was was
incredibly valuable
well everyone's touch on it knows the
first thing that popped in my head his
partnership I won't talk about it
anymore but I think it speaks to kind of
how important that aspect of any
entrepreneurial endeavor with any of
these models or other models is I think
one of the best pieces of advice we got
from other search funders was celebrate
the small victories we like to talk
about this process is climbing a
mountain then you picture the peak in
front of you and you think how wonderful
it's going to be when you get to that
peak and then when you get up there
instead of looking back down at your
accomplishment you're looking ahead at
the next peak that's twice as high as
the one you just climbed up and you're
scared and there's so much work to be
done and you came and think about what
you just did so you know we try and
every little thing we do we try and have
a little celebration I mean we finished
our ppm which is like great we wrote
like a word doc and we went out and took
the afternoon and went surfing and they
don't based heavily on David Kennedy's
yeah I mean we totally change the names
we did use it as a model
the gift that keeps on giving
actually segues nicely into my next
point which is there's a wonderful
community of entrepreneurs especially
the search fund community which is what
we've been tapping into that we reached
out to whether that's investors which is
you know the community that's directly
tied you know incentivize to be there
for you whenever you need it but more
importantly is all the former search
funders I mean we talked to a number of
people who are starting search funds
well simply because we have no idea who
they are but we just know how valuable
it was for us to talk to search funders
before us and so we it's our way of kind
of giving back a little bit because we
can't get back to those guys because
they still know more than us even though
you know we're building experiences so
we just kind of try and pass whatever
knowledge we have on to the next guys
and so you know that's been very
valuable for us to be able to reach out
to different people at different times
okay thank you let's take questions from
the group you guys help me since my back
is here help me pick some people I'll
start with JP and then maybe you guys
can pick him make sure we kept a lot
because you guys think about raising
capital versus little school or it seems
like we decided to give ourselves the
summer off after school which is in
retrospect incredibly gratuitous but we
you know we made the decision during
school that we wanted to fully engage in
the GSB community and what it had to
offer and we were both doing things that
required outside of the classroom for
the GSB community required a fair amount
of time so we did we spent a lot that
our actual in school time sorting
through this notion that we were
fundamentally redefining our
relationship so a lot of our actual work
product from you know halfway through
winter quarter and then spring quarter
was what you know what would this look
like between us let's talk about
downside scenarios let's talk about what
role what you think you'd be good at
what you think I'd be good at and then
let's go from there so we wanted our
goal was to graduate from the GSB with a
healthy sense for how we would be
working together Matt
I mention the fact that there's been a
proliferation of pants recently and you
would mention that from the aspect of
people making smaller commitments but as
you see the asset class maybe not mature
but when everyone starts searching for a
Gaston a services business I mean I
think in the big wide world of companies
out there search fun acquisitions are
such a small sliver of what's actually
going on and even we're talking about a
proliferation I mean I think the two
biggest years there were what 20 25
search funds raised so I still think
it's so small I mean that being said I
think every seems to be when search fun
starts up the guy's the first couple
industries they look at are the same
ones every other search fund in the
history of search ones has gone to look
at and so you know those those
industries in particular or kind of
picked over but that but that said
there's still tons of businesses out
there so I don't think well I don't
think in our lifetime we're gonna see a
point where the search fund motto is
blown up to the point that there's too
much capital chasing the same deals you
see the other side of it right yeah do I
mean I I think it's a sighs question
actually I mean I think that in general
as you as you look to this world for
change-of-control deals that are growth
businesses I think if you start to add
two or three million in EBIT ah it's a
pretty darn competitive world now and I
think it's a lot more competitive and
was when I did my search phones which
about ten years ago and that was a lot
more competitive than you know kind of
ten years prior and I think it's pretty
hard and you know to find a good deal
there and on the other hand so long as
you prepared to compromise a little bit
on size I think you can get great
businesses that are below kind of call
it two or three million Andy but and I
think the question is in competition
from other search funders at all its
competition from private equity and once
you get below kind of two or three
million in EBIT that's pretty hard for
private equity to really play because
there's not much - and you know the
individual deals are so small that the
transaction fees and someone kind of
tend to eat up a bunch of the equity and
so I think that so long as you're
comfortable sub two million I wouldn't
worry about it I think people who think
they're going to do
five or six million dollar EBIT da
business in a search fund I think that's
a tough I think that's a tough track to
write you know there's a Democrat at
least our thesis going in was we're
currently in in a period in our history
as a country where there's a demographic
pulse of potential business sellers
coming down the pipe so if you believe
that you know there are a bunch of boom
of the boomer generation that are now 55
to 65 who are looking for estate
planning
kind of liquidity events then that may
be a counterbalancing force but I agree
with what they say the sponsor Church so
it's and I think the composition of the
board is something that's very important
so obviously we have a several members
of outline investors who's the sponsored
PE firm but I pushed AB outside-in board
members as well because I think it's a
good dynamic it goes back to competence
you know is the control so you really
want a good board that's gonna challenge
you ask the right questions you
mentioned about keeping the tension on
you definitely feel the same thing um so
as far as the kind of decisions we're
making you know it's it's what you would
expect we've got an annual plan we've
got a quarterly plan we've got monthly
financials we have data on the business
so you know there's sort of covenant
reports for the the bank which again I I
don't love debt but it is a it's a
focusing impact on how you run your
business so yeah again it's pretty
standard it's just sort of the mini-me
version of all that we're audited GAAP
financials we're I think just on the
strategy side you know it's kind of up
to you to to see I've kind of gotten the
point now where our board isn't as
helpful on day-to-day of running the
business kind of things because we're in
pretty good control I've been able to to
sort of bring in a management team that
I'm
comfortable with now and we know the
business you know frankly better than
they're gonna know it and they've kind
of run out of the gotcha questions you
know that so now we're the next step is
to say okay this is great we like where
we're going how can we get this to be a
you know a 5x return which is a great
great questions and they still bring a
lot of goodness to bear on that I think
it's sort of a testamentary ality I mean
at the end of the day you you need their
support for the big decisions and it
evolves over time as your strategy balls
you should grow as to what's material
and you should tell them and really
becomes a day to day week in week out
thing of you know what would I not want
to be a surprise and the next board
meeting if they didn't know this now and
so early on yeah there were sort of key
personnel losses where I pick up the
phone say hey I just want you to know we
just lost a key salesperson that managed
these accounts and that becomes
important three years in double the
revenue not necessarily as an issue so I
mean I would be the same for you guys
we're still I mean we're the newbies
were still feeling it out but I think
more than anything we take the approach
if we don't want board members to ever
be surprised by anything and so like
Michael said I mean even though you're
not gonna say hey we're about to hire
this guy can we send you his resume to
see if you agree well maybe you know
cinéma an email and say hey you know
here's someone that we just hired or
here some we're about to hire but we're
still kind of feeling out where where it
is and I think it depends with different
boards and some boards would probably
just rubber-stamp
great you know awesome every time
whatever you present and other people
want to dig in a little bit more it's
kind of what you want to get out of them
as well let me answer that just a little
bit differently which is the difference
between a private equity board and a
sponsored search or you know a deal
that's owned by a private equity firm
and one that's got a typical distributed
search fun and what are the differences
between those each of those cuz I think
those are pretty marked and it's kind of
pertinent and you know the the classic
search fun board will meet once a
quarter and probably not in between they
will generally want control more or less
of the balance sheet I mean they don't
want any significant surprises on the
balance sheet if you
do anything from a data equity
perspective they're gonna want to at
least understand what's going on there
and approve everything there and then as
the guy says other than that you know
you want to kind of approve the plan and
then on the org side of things if the
CEO wants help and says hey look you
know I'm thinking about hiring X I'd
like one of you guys to interview or be
part of us and I'd like you to approve
at a minimum the option package you know
if that's what's going on to bring in a
CFO or you know kind of a VP of Sales or
something like that then they'll get
relatively involved from that
perspective the CEO more or less is
going to drive what the agenda is and
particularly on strategy that can be you
know it's kind of how long is a ball of
string kind of question right I mean you
can do very little and you can do very
much and I think with a private equity
board it's going to be very different I
mean you're going to have an operating
call once a month and you're going to go
through everything significant that's
going on inside of the P&L so you're
going to talk about all the variances
inside of the revenues and the cost of
goods sold and the SGA and I think
you're gonna want to understand any
significant differences on the balance
sheet and you won't just have approval
on the balance sheet if it's a private
equity sponsor that owns the business
they will control the balance sheet
fully they will tell you what's going on
with the balance sheet rather than the
other way around they will tell you
we're recapping we're changing the debt
structure we're gonna pay some dividends
this year or not the private equity firm
will own the balance sheet as opposed to
you know approval on the other side and
then in the HR side of things the good
news is I think if you've got
concentrated ownership they're going to
be very involved again if it's the right
firm in helping you recruit and in
saying to you hey look you know let's go
get a CFO here or let's get a VP of
Sales and they can actually take a bunch
of that work off your shoulders and do
it for you and you'll clearly always
make the decision cuz you're the CEO you
hire the team and that's gotta be the
way it's going to be they'll provide a
whole bunch of support there on the on
the organizational side and then finally
on the strategy side of things to the
extent you've got major strategic
questions that are going on you can
expect a fair amount of engagement and
again with the right firm they're
actually going to drive that provide
resources and actually do a bunch of
work for you on the side on whatever the
particular strategic issue is whether
it's tuck in acquisitions new
geographies whatever you know new
product lines they may actually provide
you with a whole bunch of bandwidth and
you know sort of smart Stanford MBAs who
can who can give you some you know some
guidance in terms of what it is you're
doing while you're busy you know kind of
up to your backside and alligator's kind
of stuff you know
so when you guys set out to you know
look for a business are you thinking you
know I wholly want to stay over side the
self under do you want to like stay
within the u.s. you say you know Canada
or maybe China Europe or something like
is that going through your head or you
kind of like whatever do I find let's
say you guys we took a pretty you it we
took a pretty dorky consulting approach
at first which was you know we're gonna
you can guess who drove the train on
that we're gonna break down you know the
30 M SAS in the US by economic viability
and quality of life and come up with 12
and then give each of our girlfriends a
pass a veto power over one and get to a
list of 10 and then Jim Ellis kindly
said to us there's no way you're gonna
put a non-economic limitation on my
option for you to buy a business so we
looked everywhere I did was and we said
up front to both to ourselves and to our
spouses both of us were married at two
working spaces and that we would look
pretty much in the NFL cities in the US
that was kind of and we defined it that
way as being you know that will be a
large enough city that there'll be an
interesting career opportunity for each
of our spouses and they signed off on
that and we were pretty open in general
with the folks we looked at now that all
being said within about eight weeks that
was gone and we were looking we looked
at a wire hanger factory in Alabama
somewhere which thank God we never
bought and we looked at a business in
the Caribbean we looked at a business in
Australia and you know at some point the
answer is you want to buy a great
business and so long as your spouses are
along with the ride particular when
you're looking at a sector and you start
to dive in and you work out that this is
a really interesting one but it's gonna
be hard to buy something decent in LA or
New York and and you've got a real
thesis around it then you go find
anything you can in that
sector and to find something great what
about international were you asking as
part of your question should you look
internationally to us I imagine an
international layer kind of complicates
things but yeah again we were we were
open to it in the end I mean we were
pretty much looking at us and but as we
looked at a couple things we got very
close with a few things in Canada we
hadn't thought about it originally we
thought we'd stay in the US we called up
our major investors and we said hey
listen we're looking at something up in
Toronto
you know Vancouver wherever it was is
that okay with you guys and they're all
pretty much yeah no that's fine so we
did the quick check-in and then we kept
on going for us as a fund we wouldn't do
anything outside of US and Canada yeah
we're happy to look at Canada there's
just like governance and you know our
ability that helps supervise and add and
then there's something around you know
the legal issues and the foreign
exchange issues and the one deal we got
very close with in Canada cost us a
fortune and in tax advice and so we're
kind of a little bit once bitten twice
shy and even looking you know in Canada
these days I can't think what was going
through her head but the first city she
took off the list was Dallas and that's
where we ended up buying a company
greatest decision that you I'm just
wondering that have you come across
people who have not make that decision
of the skill sets and what are the
things you should do right from the
early on when you decide okay we are
going to be partners June 2nd so I had a
partner and he left the business after
about a year we did the search together
I would say that he absolutely added to
the search process and to the operations
of the business somewhat but less so I
don't regret having a partner he was a
he was a good partner and was a really
good guy and a stand-up guy when things
started heading in separate directions
what I look for now when I talk with
people who are partnerships is are are
they a good partnership
do they seem to be a good partnership
have they talked through all the issues
I mean do they sort of match each other
and skill set yeah that's nice maybe one
of them is operating in one of them is
financial great but I look for people
who have really worked through the
issues and are likely to be able to
fight about stuff but the next day still
work together really well
but they really respect each other and
they've figured out a way to get through
the lows and have done some work around
it
and otherwise you know I think it's I
think it's a personal decision whether
you do a question how did you guys
figure out who was gonna be the CEO or
divider of the ultimate decision making
we didn't we had 5050 I mean we had we
have each full veto power over what the
other guy did we just divided the world
in half and so you know we never we
never resolved that frankly okay that's
for us we Lucas has the title of C we
kind of set it up where one person was
gonna gonna get the title of CEO and the
other person was gonna get the title of
president and chairman of the board to
try and make it as even as possible the
same and so you know Lucas is the
but when it comes to decision making for
us we kind of looked at as we knew each
other so well and knew that our
strengths and weaknesses were pretty
well aligned such that when any issue
came up it was probably going to be in
one of our wheel houses and not the
other one and so you know the other one
kind of generally defers to and those I
did go down a path with somebody else
thinking about doing a search fund with
them and then pulled back I'm not quite
at the last minute but I was kind of you
know fair way down the path of this
person and the thing that for me was the
red flag was I didn't feel that it was
very easy to have difficult
conversations with him already he was a
friend of mine from the GSB whose
classmate microwave ended up doing the
search fund with was not somebody who
had known all that well before we
started we spent about I didn't know him
and we spent three months working
together deciding whether or not we want
to do a search when we both want to do
something like it but this particular
individual it was just we couldn't have
the tough conversations we're a set of
things he wanted to do he said around
the search and I try and talk to him
about him and he'd kind of avoid a
minute or two got a little bit
passive-aggressive and I think the one
thing you want to get out of a
partnership is the ability to have the
other guy the other person and play
devil's advocate all the time right I
mean that's the value is when you sit
there and you say I've been doing X & Y
& Z and that person comes back and says
oh geez why is a total waste of time why
you spending time on that and why don't
you spend the time on a and B because
it's no but you know you don't want a
pat in the head and say you know nice
job kind of stuff right you want
somebody who's gonna actually make one
in one equal three and that means you
have to be prepared to give tough
feedback and have tough conversations
and so that's the only test I would make
sure I apply it if I was thought about a
partner is if you can't have tough
conversations don't do it beyond that I
think it's very personal
yes no the the short answer to that is
the short answer to that is there I've
heard of several search ones that are
either searching or running companies in
Mexico and then I've heard of a couple
in non emerging markets but
internationally in Western Europe I
think going back to a point Ryan made
earlier about the investor set that
you're approaching are necessarily folks
that are comfortable with a certain kind
of investing in a certain set of
parameters in the past that hasn't been
emerging markets but I don't see a
reason why there wouldn't be opportunity
there other than you know outside risks
leading downsize rewards I think a lot
of people kind of look at a search
funder an entrepreneur in general is
this kind of risk seeking cowboy who's
going out looking for the greatest risk
to find the greatest reward and that's
not really the way that we approach this
at all I mean we're actually taking the
complete opposite approaches like how
can we minimize our risk and so looking
at emerging markets or just generally
internationally or things that we were
just like whoa you know I mean that's
just that's kind of too much for us to
take on we're already taking on so much
risk by throwing ourselves out there in
this new venture where we are gonna you
know buy a business or we're not and
everybody's gonna know about it
everybody meaning the people that know
us but you know so we're looking for
ways to minimize risk as opposed to kind
of seek out risk fear and dread
well in the past many many people
pursued search have really done exactly
what you've said they've said well this
is not going to go wrong what do I what
could go wrong and I'm gonna find a way
to minimize those risks I'm gonna get
people to advise me I'm gonna avoid that
kind of company I'm gonna triple check
myself if we get into that sort of
situation and I'm really going to manage
those risks to a very low level by being
aware of them and afraid of them last
question from back here I hope I have
not forgotten you guys because my back
has been to you anyone back here what if
you had not done the one you did which
would you read turn it over you guys to
wrap up I'll give you a little bit I say
for me I would still do the same model
but I would have gone out and raised
more money not been so concerned about
how much of company I owned a lot of
bigger company so I still like the model
because I like the restrictions that
like you said the non-economic the
restrictions are okay for me I just
would have widened my circle and raised
more money yeah I wouldn't have done it
I mean I just wouldn't have done you
know what I did at all which was the the
straight abnormal a vanilla search fund
I would have gone the job and I would
have learned a little bit more operating
skills and then maybe after you know
kind of eight to ten years of an
operating career and hopefully you know
having learned a whole bunch of skills
then I'd have done it now it all worked
that great but if I were doing it all
all over again I don't I think I took a
bunch of risks that were unnecessary I
would do the traditional search because
I think I could have achieved a lot of
what I'd you know we did with the
sponsored search with the traditional
search and honestly is why I came out of
Northwestern we don't get the exposure
or at least personally I didn't to this
search fund model like like the GSB
community does and we don't have the
community around us of an investor so
it's exposure
and today to it so you know just wasn't
there before there was more exposure
here than there that's great
it's it's um one hard question because
both of the other two models are
contingent upon a lack of ability to do
it immediately after school and and I
I'd wanted to do it immediately after
school I'd say if I'd a preference for
the two I would like to be independently
wealthy and buy my own business I would
have done the sponsored search mostly
because the same reason I wanted to work
with a partner and Lucas is to have more
people involved in my success and so
even if it's just one private equity
firm with a few partners sitting on its
table that still would have meant more
to me and I think would have increased
my likelihood of success and if I just
done it on my own or just with Lucas
guests please closing comments and
advice of any of any level that you'd
like I think you really need to do a lot
of soul-searching about you know which
what you want to do like I mean I've
pointed out before but like Chris said
it's it's not glorious it's not all
about going out there and becoming the
CEO it's a long slog I think if if
either of us went into this because we
thought we were really gonna enjoy the
search phase of this entire process we
would have just gone into private equity
instead but we didn't think we're gonna
like it and it exceeded our expectations
in that regard in the sense that it
wasn't really that much fun and we look
we kind of glorified a little bit when
we look back on it but there are a lot
of you know stressful days with the two
of us sitting in our in a room saying is
he gonna accept evaluation is he not
going to accept evaluation maybe we went
too high oh maybe we're throwing away
money and then I think you know a lot of
it comes down to what do you want and
what's gonna make you happy in life and
even when it came down to what
industries we wanted to look at we
looked at what our what industries are
we gonna be happy managing in and what
are we gonna enjoy and what are we gonna
be good at because so much but it's a
personal decision I'm gonna focus on the
positive here
when I started my second year I just
couldn't fly out just couldn't picture
myself doing anything else and it was a
decision that required me to forego my
sponsorship my consulting firm which
didn't sit well with the members of the
my parents didn't sit well my parents it
it required it required you know
foregoing a lot of other opportunities I
was thinking about doing but and it was
a you know a hot mess along the way but
today you know I couldn't picture myself
doing anything else I'm incredibly happy
doing this I'm incredibly fulfilled
every day to come in and have the
ability to think critically about
something and then talk to the folks
that will help make that happen and then
see it happen and see that garner
success and results that's incredibly
satisfying to me it's not for everyone I
think doing with the partners was was
critical for me so I would just
encourage you to think about whether
this is the right time in your career
and if it is you know reach out to the
search meant community start to get the
questions you'd want answered answered
and then take that leap you say the
thing hasn't been covered here and yours
paths are in years past has been covered
more sort of the personal impacts and
sacrifices and you know I think one of
the things is is when you're thinking
about is also think about your spouse or
who you're with because it's you know
the opportunity costs are pretty
significant and what you do on a day to
day basis and the stresses and
everything I look back in hindsight I'm
glad I did it and I'm very happy with
where I'm at but that's not always the
case throughout and if you don't have a
supportive family environment spouse
when I bought this company you know in
the four years happened I bought the
company we bought the company we had two
kids my wife got her master's at UCSF
and it was only through the support of
family and her that we got it done and
when you're making that decision to go
do this you're not making it just for
you you can't insulate your your family
so be sure that everything at home is
good because it will wreck you if it's
not
amen to that I started the search with
the wife I now have a wife and three
kids and it's only been three years yeah
it's crazy but to have that support and
insert of the buy-in of where you might
end up and some of the unknowns and the
risk when you are walking away from sort
of known sort of comfortable lifestyle
and then you know your partner needs to
be committed to it for sure I think
that's usually important just I guess
practically I just say think through the
rest for sure again everybody it's an
individual decision but the professional
risks and the financial risks I thought
that one page the histogram of the
returns was was pretty pretty pretty
telling - you know again not if there's
a couple of his type returns when you
pull that out it's it's it's interesting
right because you're not the investor
investing in the asset class you're the
you're the individual and there's a
there's a lot of variability on that
return and that one page captured it
great but not not to scare you off I
guess as far as tactics now I mean again
if if you're really just playing it safe
right that entrepreneurship is not
really about totally going you know by
the book but any good gambler does try
to minimize the risk you said you think
those risks are representative of how
you see it today so I didn't feel that
it was a very risky approach that I took
and the reason I say it is because for
me it was a career progression I had you
know been a general manager some
experience before now you know a
reasonably solid private equity firm yet
had sponsored me if I went out and I
believe you guys said it if if I went to
good company and I was gonna get you
know be able to do a decent-sized deal
did a good job even if it wasn't a home
run it was just a solid double now I had
that on my track record with with
experience behind it that you know I
felt like my career could still take a
good path and I'd get it next week
the bat so that's why I felt pretty
comfortable about it right after I
explained to my wife why that salary was
kind of gonna be like 60% of what it
used to be for a little while but on the
process itself I learned a lot from the
folks behind me you know and I think you
guys did a good job about it just be
systematic just be ruthless about you
know cold calling really getting as many
good deals as you can in the top of the
funnel you know in qualify them out as
fast as possible and I saw a lot of
people who came behind me do a very good
job that I learned from you know had
Salesforce up and just you know really
were like good salespeople you got to
create a full pipeline just to close one
deal but that that's the way to do it
yeah I'll leave it at that I'd be
curious tee I mean I know you like about
risk and all that how how you compared
to the risk in your business now where
you have at times entrepreneurs running
so okay so I'll try I'll try and touch
on that I mean it is all about risk and
you know I think she won't you put a
really one fact I had a note here and he
stole it from you know great gamblers
who take risks you know first of all
minimize always those risks I mean
aggressively ruthlessly and well you
know I think was Ryan was talking about
that a second ago and the second thing
that they do is they they kind of
minimize the impact of those risks if
you know that there's some stuff you
can't control that's going to be a risk
for you then it's minimizing the impact
thereof so what does that actually mean
I think again and you know social and
said it so well on the sourcing side of
things it's all about being ruthless and
covering as much ground as you possibly
can it's all about cutting bait as fast
as you can undi 'ls that and that are
never going to get done and you'll
quickly work out which deals are never
going to get done and it is so seductive
to spend time in a transaction because
there's somebody who wants to talk to
you because most people don't want to
talk to you and and being honest and
ruthless about that with your time is
important and I think on the execution
side of things making sure you don't
screw up means bringing in somebody
whether it's a partner it's an investor
in the normal
rich fun world it's a sponsored search
doesn't matter but bring somebody else
in to play devil's advocate all the
great investing firms of the world
whether they're hedge funds venture
firms private equity firms or what have
you all have some sort of a devil's
advocate model whereby there's somebody
proposing a transaction that somebody
else chucking rocks at it and trying to
knock it down and don't rely on the
general kind of investor set that you'll
have inside of a search fund to do that
and then finally when it comes time to
run us you know how you maximize the
chances of success on that is I think
again the the control issue is always
something that's there and there's you
know there's really two ways of managing
boards and I think the worst advice I
got on my board and was given by
somebody who has generally given me the
very best advice in my career and who
shall remain nameless and other than the
fact that he's teaching here at Stanford
on a regular basis and the advice was
and it was something on the lines of the
court-appointed state psychiatrist is
not your friend yeah and he said and
that's your board and in general what he
meant was you know don't reveal too much
to your board they're the only guys who
can fire you you know so never present a
problem until you've got a solution and
never bringing them in too early into
stuff right and I think that's terrible
advice I think in general what you want
to do when you're executing is you want
to be as open as you possibly can be and
you want to you want to get hard and
challenging folks who will sit there on
your board and who will beat you up
early rather than subsequently kind of
dance on Your Grave if it's once it's
too late and when you've made some
mistakes that they ultimately you have
to make some tough decisions based on
and so to me this is all around there
are some risks you can't avoid if you're
going to do a search point you will have
all of your eggs in one basket and
trying to do everything you can to
minimize the risk there and and if
that's how you minimize the chances then
I think minimizing the impact again I
think Sean's like the smartest guy at
this table because that's exactly how I
would do it I would do it in my career
when if it all went you know kind of
belly-up that I would that I had built
the kind of glittering track record that
he had such that I would swap swap slot
back into another great role but it
happened to me it hadn't gone too well
I'd have been scrambling to try and find
something and and so I think you know
the minimize the impact is different
from the minimize the chances yeah on
the impact side of things if the biggest
risk is to your career which I think it
is then build your career in your
network to the extent that it doesn't
feel like quite as much of a risk as a
tip
as for folks coming out of the JSP
please the assignment is to midnight on
Wednesday and thank you to our guests
for coming in sharing